this guy his response to being exposed
as a racist was to claim that he's being
attacked by people who are anti-semitic
on on X and I'm just like that's kind of
Mark I got to be honest that's kind of
the Kevin spacy argument like Kevin spy
gets accused of rape and then he's like
I'm gay and it's like yes well that may
be but you were accused of rape so uh
write this way to uh jail sir and then
we'll have a trial you know and then I
guess the witnesses like several of the
witnesses or or something happened and
you like went what like Witnesses or
victims died or something like that oh
yeah but I think yeah I think he was
acquitted wasn't he I think so all of
his accusers passed away I believe I
don't think true maybe one that didn't
there were a couple I think that like
but but I think he was acquitted and so
if he was like that that it is what it
is like you know if if that's the courts
find I don't know what else I can say
doesn't mean I completely agree with it
but I'm not going to attack a guy who
who went through the system in that way
that being said back to Mark cubin who
quite literally fights tooth and nail to
be like I want to hire based on race and
he's screaming it